What advice do you have for
beginners who may not have a lot of programming experience?
>> well, on one hand it is an awesome time to be doing that because
the field's kind of exploding right now.
There's sort of a whole data movement, big data, like everybody's talking about
data and at the same time, you know, there are just as many people trying to
make sense of all that data and usually are [INAUDIBLE] so.
In terms of advice it's,
it's really hard to give general advice because you know the good news and
the bad news is there's so many different ways into this field.
If somebody's like a student wanting to go to school looking at programs you
know there are programs like this Udasity program there aren't a ton of sort of
you know majors, or even Graduate programs yet in information visualization.
So there's no, kind of obvious one place to get all the skills that you need.
And, and what I think is exciting about the field,
is that people come into it from so many different areas.
Like I know, you know, architects, industrial designers, graphic designers,
statisticians, mathematicians.
Like, everybody has some sort of core prior background, and
they bring that with them to the field.
So, you know, one thing I encourage people to do is,
take advantage of whatever your personal background is.
And, like, bring that to the field, and see what you can do with it.
>> Hm.
>> now, on like, a more practical level, usually, people want to know, well,
what book should I read or what program should I learn or how do I, you know.
And again I think that depends like,
I work with students who are coming from a design background, and so for them
it doesn't make sense to dive into like, the most technical code heavy projects.
It makes sense to build on what they already know, so for somebody with a design
background I would say you know, start with, with illustrator.
Start doing things manually and
like, figuring out ways to connect the things you know how to do to data.
Somebody who's coming from computer science, mathematics, something like that.
Obviously if you leverage you know,
your skills being able to use some of these more advanced tools.
But you might have to learn like the design language and the visual principles
and looking at human perception and psychology and like how do
we interpret colors, and scales, and size, and proportion and all this stuff.
So, unfortunately, the answer is a whole sort of, it depends and
it's going to be a little bit different for everyone and I think that's okay.
It's actually what's kind of exciting about the field is everybody has their
own perspective.
>> Great.